Chef Russell Wilson took over the Bronco
last year and it quickly fell on hard
times but now they're calling in the one
guy who may be able to save it
this is the worst run restaurant in the
history of restaurants are you always
this mean or is it just for the cameras
[Music]
what's the most important part of
running a successful restaurant that
Everyone likes me but no I work front of
house so I could defend whatever we're
serves up lots of scrambles the
occasional duck and a bunch of turnovers
later you know my job is to run the
place to the tables but a lot of times
rush just fakes the handoff
I'll just do it myself
what do you have our menu is unlimited
menus need limits this is way to run a
business
between you and me the competition on
the AFC West Side isn't as intense as
you think the Chargers basically run a
social media restaurant but it turns out
ultimately they don't even deliver I
hope you love room for dessert my dudes
oh God it burns
why does this keep happening Raiders
just hope everyone gets distracted by
the show
excuse me this is not good yeah that is
correct with all the rumors no one could
even get into the cheese restaurant
Travis Travis are you meeting Taylor
Swift inside oh why is everyone making a
big deal about this thing I bring up all
the time
I mean yes we won it for you but it was
also just the Bears we made some big
changes Russ finally listened to me and
agreed to wear a recipe wristband but
it's so heavy service type shifts all
hands on stacked
thank you
[Music]